how is it going guys welcome to a video
in Co Tecna toriel's my name is Matt
your local today's video technician the
one and only because this is my channel
yeah here we go we're gonna I'm gonna
show you how to install Linux on
basically any computer you want I'm
trying to keep this very simple so I
might be skipping a lot of technical
stuff and staying out of technical stuff
I just want to keep this in a format
that anybody can follow so here we go
had went to DistroWatch calm because
it's a it's a sweet site to just check
how distributions are doing and which
ones are popular and just kind of feel
around Linux distributions a little bit
it sort of I love the site I spent a lot
of time here as a child
you
well I've noticed that MX limit Linux
was pretty far up there and since that's
the case we're going to go ahead and use
it
Hey so I already went ahead and
downloaded it I basically just clicked
on it and then I clicked on their
website and then I clicked on download
and then current release yadda yadda
direct download I just did direct
download and I went and got an ISO file
an ISO file which in case you don't know
is a disk image of some sort usually
meant for CDs but we don't have CDs
anymore everybody's using USB CDs are a
thing of the past or so they're going
that way so what we got is these flash
drives now this one is clearly about as
old as a CD and I've got a bunch of
these flash drives for everything this
one is even a Wi-Fi device
I don't really use them for data I just
use them for disk images basically
because what we did after we downloaded
it is we launched this program called
Rufus I'll bring up Rufus here
so what Rufus does his it'll allows you
to put an ISO on to one of these
handy-dandy little USB drives clicking
them around for effect okay and so I
went ahead and done that now I've
already completely finished this but I'm
gonna start it over again just so you
can see it so I'm gonna do a close all
right cam cam meet meet setup setup meet
YouTube hello YouTube
so this one I just imaged right here and
I'm going to go ahead and eject it now
pull that sucker 10 we'll grab another
one say this Kingston one one that you
want to image check your data make sure
you're not over writing anything
important but you basically need to
drive so this one pops up and says it's
El Ubuntu I can go look at it so there's
a problem whatever so I'd be fine with
imaging this one it's probably a broken
installed for all I know what we do is
we launch Rufus now Rufus is an
interesting tool because it just runs
Rufus is a small application that
creates bootable USB drives so you
basically just go here download it and
run the little thing you get it I've got
it in a download folder currently so I
just double clicking it runs but I have
some old versions elsewhere and as you
can see this is portable and so what you
get here is it tries to find the device
but you can pick from this drop-down and
pick the device that you're looking at
that you want to image and then you pick
an ISO or a disk image well I guess you
can pick which one I'm doing ISO here
but as you can see Rufus handles
multiple things so then you just hit
select over here and we can go to
downloads and I can go find an ISO
there's a bunch of them here looking at
MX so I'll just click MX and then we get
some more options here I always leave
everything default and you just hit
start and gives you some warnings and
stuff say ok and then a final warning
it's gonna destroy all the previous data
so you'd hit OK here and it goes through
its process saying if it completes
successfully you can now boot with this
puppy I'm gonna hit cancel here though
cuz I've already done it but that's how
use Rufus it's part of the process of
knowing how to get Linux on a computer
these days so it's a rather important
step
so just to recap so far you basically go
get a Linux distro you want from distro
watch pick one pick cool one or just
pick a popular one so you know there's a
lot of documentation use Rufus there
might there's other ways other than
Rufus Rufus is just a very easy one to
image with and now let's go on to par
three
part three okay part three is actually
rather hard to do because I basically
have to go install this on something
obviously I don't want to install this
on my main computer because it's you
know I've got my workflow going I don't
want to mess with it really but but I
did just get a new laptop and it needs
Linux the only problem is it's all USB C
and I don't have a USBC adapter so I'm
gonna have to continue this in a few
days because I'm ordering one or maybe
I'll go somewhere if I can manage to
avoid the people just people in general
all right so there you go and we'll get
to the next part what and what will seem
like an instant to you but for me it's
gonna be days
okay so I'm gonna go out on a little bit
of a limb here this is not the laptop I
was just talking about this is a
different one and it could use Linux as
well it has Windows right now but I'm
not particularly partial to having
windows on it in fact bought it for
Linux got like 32 gigs of memory it's
very much a developer workstation so
that was the intention of it and it's
supposed to have Linux but I could never
get Linux on it because it has an nvidia
quadro graphics card and every time I
try to put Linux on there I get this
garbled nonsense USB if it doesn't fit
flip it over is that this at the rule
okay got it
cheese so I'm gonna power this thing on
I believe it's f12 to get to the BIOS or
boot menu so I'm gonna spam f12 and your
computer will vary you often have to
spam something in the beginning to get
to the BIOS and this is a little tricky
too Oh apparently f12 is network boot
but that presents an error because
there's no network boot system and then
it gets me to the Start menu which is
good enough and hopefully this doesn't
wash out too much come on camera don't
fail me now so we get boot options here
external USB Drive is the top one it's
alright and we get to the main installer
for the customized boot and one of them
was just a standard boot it looks like
says May 31st 2020 I guess I'm just
gonna pick the top one the other stuff
is advanced option the memory test in
boot rescue I don't want to do boot
rescue I don't want to do a memory test
I don't really want to do Advanced
Options my first install customized boot
no let's just do the standard one at the
top it's not name so it makes me
question what it is exactly
it's MX 19.2 x64 just says mates already
first 2020 so I guess this is the
default version that default to install
and we're gonna go with that just to see
how it goes by default oh and we've got
some weird screen tere and it looks like
the Nvidia support is not there on this
one either green tear thing is just got
the
wrong drivers it's trying to
processes though it's like I guess an
AMD or an Intel card but it's an Nvidia
so yeah that's why I haven't been able
to get Lennox on this thing I can I
don't know if anyone has any tips about
that let me know
and we're back it's a whole new day
well USBC thing on the other computer
not going to happen anytime soon so I
figured I'd get this done and what I did
is just I went and grabbed another PC
that I was just being stored elsewhere
anyway I wouldn't got it and it's a
think pad this is a think pad it's an L
430 this thing actually got me through
several years of college and I use Linux
on it a bunch so I know Linux works
great on this machine however I did end
up putting windows on it at some point
because someone else was using it and
they didn't want Linux but they're no
longer really using it and it doesn't
really matter that much so I'm just
gonna pop Linux on here so we've got the
MX Linux from last time from earlier
doing the whole Rufus thing or stuff and
we're gonna power down this thing and I
don't know you should go through the
proper power down but since I don't care
about what's on this disk or anything
really I'm just gonna hold power until
it shuts down and now another important
thing is you want to be connected to a
power source you want to be connected to
a power source when you're installing of
course I mean I know it's kind of common
sense but it's sometimes it's something
that some people may overlook and it
could cause serious problems if it dies
in the middle of an install there we go
interrupt normal startup press Enter it
says now it's beeping at me all right
let's give it a second we seem to have
interrupted it and we can get the boot
manager now there is a USB hard disk
drive now if I could actually get into
the BIOS which I'm sure there's a way I
could show you more stuff but you can't
even hardly see the screen anyway so
I'll leave that to the comments and
maybe the details below and maybe
editing - well I'm basically gonna
choose the very first option looks like
the focus is getting destroyed this
camera so it looks like we got to a
screen must be loading it's not really
showing us anything okay and we've got
to the desktop it appears we've booted
to a live mode yeah this is just live so
this is
approximately what its gonna look like
once we get fully booted all right so
usually there's an installer and it
looks like there's one on the desktop
here I know you can't read that but it
says installer install Linux so we're
gonna double click that and it should
take us to the actual installer and give
us some options about what to do with
our disk right now this live mode is
running entirely off this USB even if
you get a laptop if you get a laptop or
a computer with no hard drive no OS and
you just want to boot into it and do
something you can make one of these
discs or one of these USB s the same way
and just boot a computer with it
however the bios options have to be set
right most corporate computers and those
business computers have something set in
the BIOS that locks it down and says hey
you can't boot from USB only from this
hard drive but most consumer grade
laptops and other laptops or if you have
access to the BIOS to change those
settings then you can boot the Linux
that's often one of the things that
people get stuck on and I can't remember
what that's called for the life of me
I'd know it
it's the Installer hit next and looks
like there's a partition tool there's
custom install I'm gonna run the
partition tool it opens up gparted Shoji
part is gonna give some now I know from
experience that if I if I shrink one of
the windows partitions Hey
like shrink it and remove some of its
unused space it will bug windows out
until I do a repair on Windows so I know
Bisquick did a video about installing
linux and he said well Windows doesn't
work we're just gonna erase it you don't
have to do that you can actually do the
startup repair and it will fix that and
you will be able to boot to Windows and
Linux but in general that whole startup
error if you're getting that far and all
you really need to do is run the startup
repair on Windows and it should allow
you to boot back in the window don't
really want to keep windows on here and
I don't really want to mess with discs
so I'm just gonna use the entire disk in
this case but if you don't want to I was
just looking carefully at some guide
that explains the partitions there's
actual text on here there's text right
here but there's just no way that this
camera is picking it up so I don't know
but basically I'm gonna say use the
entire disk and hit next okay to format
the disk I'm gonna hit yes install grub
for Windows and Linux I'm at the Master
Boot Record here cuz if I take it off of
this thing just get it right up to it
maybe that oh Jesus is what I got to do
my stand doesn't reach to here alright
and now we get the option to basically
says I'm macro reboot we finished up
here and asks if we want to reboot out
of this live in live mode go ahead and
hit yes and boom we're gonna reboot and
we'll be in to the system and it's just
gonna boot up and it should go right to
Linux now we'll see if I did something
terribly wrong or not okay so we get to
this boot manager OH
so what do we hit yes this should go to
a grub boot loader not the
I mean let's just hit enter on the
windows one doesn't do anything we'll
pull out the Baathists USB and then
power it on we'll see if that makes a
difference print but this is obviously
the hard drive there's only one in here
the one that's highlighted white there
so I'm gonna hit enter
and oh it does nothing so I've got some
kind of bug okay so upon further
investigation of this computer looks
like seem bad why can I go back see what
lets me go back here I don't know I
don't know what the heck is doing I just
hit arrows okay
well under Advanced Options there was a
safe video mode so I'm thinking safe
video mode might actually work on our
whole Nvidia problem with the other
laptop and I think I'm gonna test that
out next
but for now I'm still playing around
with this think pad maybe custom install
didn't know let's just use the entire
disk and maybe it's cuz I hit MBR I'm
just gonna leave this all default I'm
not gonna touch anything
not I guess I'll enter a username and
stuff okay we're back to the screen
after installation completing so I'm
just gonna hit finish here sorry for the
shaky camera holding it with my hand and
it's gonna reboot so last time it didn't
boot it let's see what happens this time
we didn't check MBR that's the only
difference we made the only thing we
changed why I can really see the dust
from this camera it looks like it boots
fine
so the MBR thing wasn't working maybe
it's because I wiped Windows I don't
know but it appears we are booting into
MX Linux as of right now that's new
little think so but look looks like it's
just prompting for my password there
all right what do we get there's the
desktop looks very clean very nice
little startup thing hard to see on this
camera so I went through every hotkey on
this keyboard every hockey has in the
function keys trying to figure out which
one was the BIOS and I eventually did
figure out it was what what was it hold
on I forget my tip it was f1 I think I
think it's f1 f1 pressing f1 makes a lot
beep goes to the BIOS okay so I'm just
gonna flip through these this is the
yeah I'm just gonna flip through I don't
think I need to really talk
now I think it's time guys we try the
Zen book with safe mode will it boot
past that annoying Quadro Nvidia driver
problem that nobody has fixed on Linux
installers find out more on this episode
okay so we're back to the old Zenbook
and we're gonna shut down its windows
that's running right now and when we
boot what key is it what keys are gonna
be on the Lenovo we were looking for F 1
and F 12 pretty much f1 was BIOS f12 was
boot menu think yeah f10 was test
diagnostic so what is it on this HP Zen
I say Zen book this is a Z book this is
an HP is eBook I do I did just get a Zen
book that's the one with a USB see stuff
that I was talking about earlier but I'm
not gonna mess with installing that on
there but I could later a my later and
if I do if this gets you know if people
will like this kind of stuff I'll keep
making it because I enjoy making this
kind of content personally okay so we're
gonna power this up we're gonna try
escape I recall it being escape I don't
remember exactly but escapes usually a
good first try on most brands spam in
that escape spamming it too much no you
can't spam it too much it's got to do
something there's literally nothing on
the screen it's a blank screen do this
all day I got rhythm
I got a rhythm computer I can spam your
skate key all day maybe I should just
let up I'm gonna let out there it is it
was literally waiting on me to stop
spamming it so this is the startup menu
escape got me the startup menu and there
is a BIOS setup so it looks like and get
to everything from escape here on this
HP C book so we're going to go to boot
nice options now actually let's go to
the BIOS setup and let's just make sure
that safe boot is off boot options and
we're gonna hit escape again oh it does
say down in the corner on this one to
hit escape for startup menu that's very
handy okay so we're gonna go to boot
device options and we're gonna boot to
the external USB Drive sorry you can't
see this well but it says the external
USB Driver and I hit enter of course
this is the drive look at it go yeah
that's as good as it gets guys okay so
there's safe video which makes me thinks
it's gonna bypass this Quadro Nvidia
card problem we're getting on every
Linux version we try to install so let's
press it safe video how safe is it
not very safe that's the same thing
we're getting before they went out there
know how to get Linux on the hpz book
with a Quadro graphics card I'll post
the ignore I'll put it in post the exact
model in spec but I've got nothing I've
searched high and low at one point and I
just gave up and Here I am again once
again giving up on putting Linux on the
HPC book I would love to have it's a
perfect computer for it
then comes with 32 gigs of RAM and a
high-end high seven it's kind of an
older computer at this point but it is
such a beast it's great for development
and I just really wouldn't use Linux on
it just really gonna use Linux only man
all right well that's gonna do it for
this video please leave a like please
leave a like a man I've probably been
messing up the audio sorry about all the
quality and production issues I'm just
doing this at my desk kind of on a whim
so hopefully it's entertaining enough to
to garner some views and is actually
useful enough so peace out guys stay
safe out there don't do anything I
wouldn't do which is buy a MacBook okay
I don't have anything against Mac books
I just I just wanted to slip that in
there
you